see jordan montgomery the big lefty down
in philly
bryce harper up
that one's hit sharply right over the
shoulder of angel hernandez the umpire
and into right center field of base hit
the runners on first and second jt real
muto that one's out toward left field
going back on it is gardner back toward
the wall it is gone
a three-run home run
he got a hanging curve ball and he
didn't miss it and the phillies jump out
to the early lead
zac eflin is pretty darn free and easy
as well i mean the ball just coming out
not a ton of effort that'll bring gary
sanchez up
that's a beautiful spot on the outside
part of the plate another
strikeout looking two outs talkman
grounded to third in the first
he lined it right up the middle for a
base hit one run scores
here comes urschella
he scores it's a two-run single for
talkman who continues to produce and
it's three two bills
and here's stanton
swinging events
got him for the second time three
strikeouts for eplin
phil gosselin the hitter gosselin struck
out his first time up
out toward left center field hicks on
the run he's not gonna get it it's a one
hop off the wall two runs will score
phil gosselin continues his torrid start
it's a two-run double and the phillies
lead it five to two it's amazing what
you can do you keep your hands back
i think he'll be off running here
does go the pitch is a strike three
called what a throw it's a strikeout
throw out double play for strikeouts for
zach keplin what a throw that was a seed
what a throw
how quickly did he get to his feet
to sanchez
called strike three on the outside part
of the plate
five strikeouts for effluent
michelle
a little bit he knows with roman quinn's
speed
nice
right field line that's a fair ball
it's going to the corner and romans on
his way to second flying toward third
hochman really took his time getting to
that baseball two out triple for roman
quinn
[Applause]
archela lines one into left center field
cutting over his quinn great job cutting
it off bobbles but urchella was going
for two anyway he gets himself a lead
off double so here's a man who needs a
hit in a big way and that's gary sanchez
he struck out twice looking at pitches
off the outside corner
fly ball right field and deep going back
is harper and the ball is gone
a home run for gary sanchez harper's
playing as if it was in play but the
umpire is saying home run so a two-run
shot for sanchez
and boy did he ever need that and so did
the yankees it's 5-4 yankees extend
their home run streak that's home run
number 24.
hector is on to try to finish off the uh
the ball game he's gonna have to get
four outs and the first guy he face he
will face is aaron judge john carlos
stanton is over at third base three
infielders on the left side
by the first pitch fastball i think that
surprised judge that he got a first
pitch basketball
got another one
no one's fouled off the leg
the o2 pitch
in the dirt
swing gonna miss he got him
what a pitch
couple fastballs couple of splits and
the phillies are out of the eighth
inning
they're gonna work in the top of the
night trying to save this one for the
phillies
oh two pitch hit in the air to right
field not deep playable for harper
says he has it
and one out
pop up into short left field
gregorius is under it waiting for it
and he puts it away
all right so dj le mayhew
and the 2-2 coming
back toward the middle and
knocked down by kingry throws to first
not in time
so hochman that one served down to left
field with the outfielders playing back
that's going to drop in for a hit le
mayhew stops at second
so the tying run is at second base
luke voight
out toward right center field roman
quinn
on the track near the scoreboard makes
the catch and the ball game is over it
took 27 pitches
a couple of hits by the yankees made it
tense but hector naris is able to save
the day for the fills as they hang on
and win it five to four